Megan McCain's a mom of two I'm really
really happy right now the TV
personality and her husband Ben Dominic
welcome to their second daughter
together the couple already shared
two-year-old Liberty I'm so obsessed
with her Megan first announced the
pregnancy in September telling the Daily
Mail quote Ben and I feel so blessed
that we will be adding a new member to
our family in the article she revealed
at the time she was more than halfway to
meeting their newest addition it's
amazing I mean having a child is the
greatest thing I've ever done I love it
so much the former co-host of the view
and her hubby got engaged back in
November of 2017 and only Weeks Later
tied the knot now fast forward three
years enter baby Liberty I just think
having a baby and having a daughter in
particular because I love strong women
and I feel like my parents raised me to
be such a strong woman that I have this
responsibility to like obviously love
and nurture but I also want her to be
strong and prepared for the world as the
couple planned to expand their family A
year later Megan tragically suffered a
miscarriage when you have a miscarriage
and again I can only go off of my
personal experience I really blame
myself and I thought that maybe because
I had you know had this like chaotic
experience on a late night show or
because I had you know I had as tough
like I I used to argue on television for
a living and I felt like maybe if I had
been in like a more Serene environment
or I was a calmer person or I was
younger that this wouldn't have happened
I was really unprepared for obviously
having a miscarriage but for birth as
well I felt like people only talk about
the really good parts of motherhood and
they're amazing but it's hard it's
physical it's arduous having a
miscarriage is the one of the worst
things I've ever experienced but after
the tough times came Megan's rainbow
baby a second daughter as Megan told ET
last year being a mom to Liberty
introduced her to a love she's never
known I just didn't think I could love
anything the way that I loved my dad I
felt like that kind of pure love was
gone and like it was like something I
experienced it was over now but I love
her even like I mean I don't like to
like gauge love but I love her just as
much if not more and it's this pure
feeling of just she's like perfect like
even like you know when she like spits
up or like I have to change her diaper I
think it's perfect but I'm it's such a
cliche and we know it's sure to be
passed on to her new bundle of joy
[Music]